[Music]
hey head of the wedding of my sister yes
I am so where's your fiance wait is this
him hey I'm Ben I was for hall pass on
your break wow you are a child it's
pretty long flight do you want anything
from the front of the boat I'm all good
on Creatine and smell like insecurity
nothing small about me what
the that's the jerk could be got with
when she was on a break from Jonathan I
could never be with someone like him
this girls are
disastrous
[Applause]
oh look going to our wedding
sorry is it going stranger what's going
on over there they dated she crushed his
heart that man does not have a heart no
way honey look who's here who is that my
ex Jonathan my parents have been trying
to get us back together he's like a son
to us maybe we should just tell everyone
we're together what it would s that
problem for me and you clearly want
Margaret she seesure with me she wants
what she can't have there's no way we
can convince anyone we actually like
each other you know I still think about
that night we spent together shut up no
I'm
serious no matter how it ended it still
pretty
[Applause]
amazing convincing enough let's do
it honey here he is oh no I'm with Ben
so is it like we just got together or we
been sing around let's just be
affectionate Showtime permission to put
my left hand on your right buttock
granted
not a magic
lamp hey little guy God damn it see you
tonight we have to kick it up a not nice
touch nice
TR oh no no it's going to be hot when
are you ever going to learn [__] it it's
fine Titanic me are they watching are
they doing Titanic they're gone show's
over oh my
god do you have a mo or something any
but no
what the
f what the one might be in
you I'm good it's probably a better way
to check than what I did it's a bad idea
right what did we miss what did we miss
[__] it it's
[Music]
fine